können Sie sich freuen wenn er mitmacht
Boris Palmer sollten wir eine Partei
gründen freue ich mich immer wenn
Menschen mitmachen die vernünftig sind
und die solide Ansichten haben sie
teilen noch etwas die gemeinsame
Abneigung gegen die Grünen
war bis vor kurzem Mitglied der Grünen
also unterschreiben würde weiß ich nicht
aber er hat sich natürlich auch an den
Grünen gerieben und ich glaube dass er
einer von denen ist die was viele
Menschen ja empfinden oder auch spüren
die einfach das nicht erträglich finden
wie die Grünen abgehoben sind wie sie
sich von den Problemen normaler Menschen
entfernt haben wie sie offenbar wirklich
glauben dass alle Leute in diesem Land
so leben wie ihre Kumpel in der
hochpreisigen hippen großstadtblase wo
sich das Leben eben dann zwischen
Hafermilch magate und Lastenfahrrad
abspielen